bonjour à tous on peut très facilement
vous voler vos dernières photos dès lors
vous avez un hayon et 11 en attendant la
mise à jour d'apple je vais vous montrer
comment ça marche on va faire attention
parce qu'on peut se faire piquer ses
photos assez facilement c'est parti
[Musique]
la faille de sécurité dont je vous parle
pas moi qui les ai découvertes elle a
été mise au jour par la chaîne youtube
idevice et je vous invite à lire dans
leur chaîne d'ailleurs je vous mets le
lien dans la description les mises à
jour ios font toujours super avec leur
lot de nouveautés mais aussi leur lot
d'inconvénients
il ya souvent des bugs sont corrigés par
les mises à jour mais là on est plus que
sur un bug on est sur un vrai problème
au niveau de la sécurité une vraie
faille de sécurité
on peut très très facilement venir vos
piques et toutes vos dernières photos et
les récupérer assez facilement je vais
vous montrer comment ça marche
la toute première chose j'ai besoin du
smartphone ici qui sera le smartphone de
tests qui me servira pour montrer
effectivement comment ça marche alors
normalement là dessus je n'ai pas le
code c'est le téléphone que vous avez
trouvé ou votre téléphone qui est
emporté par quelqu'un quand on a une île
numéro de téléphone il est absolument
rien ni aucun code et celui ci c'est
soit votre iphone soit votre tablette
alors je vous explique la toute première
chose que je vais vous montrer
c'est ma version de ios c'est la version
11 points 1
on va très très bien ici alors mon
smartphone est verrouillé je ne peut
strictement rien en faire la toute
première chose c'est de récupérer le
numéro de téléphone voyez là dessus je
n'ai pas de coach ivy il n'est pas
reconnu ça ne marche pas quel est mon
numéro de téléphone
la céline guinot il veut pas le montrer
on va utiliser notre méthode cas les
matches donc on récupère le numéro de
téléphone assez facilement c'est même
relativement inquiétant maintenant ce
que je vais faire je vais utiliser ce
numéro de téléphone ici parlent en syrie
je vais utiliser ce numéro de téléphone
ici directement pour faire un appel
facetime audio depuis ma tablette et
vous allez voir que ça me permettra
d'appeler et vous allez tout de suite
comprendre comment ça marche ce
téléphone là et verrouillé jeu peut
strictement rien en faire j'utilise
j'ouvre facetime
j'appelle monsieur greu ce smartphone la
dont j'ai rentré le numéro de téléphone
en facetime audio là c'est l'ipad qui
m'appelle je mets dans messages
personnalisés
ça va m'ouvrir cette partie à l'eau
fraîche pour accrocher ses bons donc la
voyez je ne peux pas activer les photos
donc ce que je vais faire je vais
répondre avec des emoji je mets trois
emoji peu importe lesquels je n'en vois
pas et je vais chercher à ouvrir par
cyril notre application ouvrir les
réglages
ça ne marche pas ce que je fais j'éteins
directement je fais la même manip
j'appelle monsieur grehan facetime audio
directement sur le même numéro de
téléphone et là je fais messages
personnalisés
ça me reconnais les troisièmes moggi
tout à l'heure je peux annuler et vous
voyez qu'il ya un vrai changement là
j'ai accès à mon menu directement avec
mes applications et la petite flèche sur
le côté je clique et là j'ai accès à mes
photos à toutes mes photos récentes
alors pas tout tout l'appareil mais
jacques ces photos récentes de l'envoyer
là par exemple typiquement c'est na dé
cannes que j'avais il ya quelques temps
où j'en ai trois au hasard que j'ai fait
remarquer of the les envoient et elles
vont partir directement ici donc là des
jeunes de recevoir déjà le sms hop au
louvre le sns vu que les photos peuvent
être un peu lourde peut mettre du temps
voyez typiquement j'ai envoyé cette
photo elle vient d'arriver là alors ça
c'est ce que j'ai fait tout à l'heure
sont exactement les mêmes images mais
vous voyez ça marche comme ça c'est
super facile et c'est même trop facile
c'est même carrément inquiétant
voilà un peu ce qu'il en est de cette
faille de sécurité d'ios 11 alors l'idée
c'était d'aller pirates et les autres
mais par contre c'est très intéressant
parce que tout ça est juste très
clairement certains points de sécurité
qu'on peut rencontrer sur les mises à
jour de votre smartphone
a priori apple devrait corriger ça assez
rapidement mais néanmoins il faut quand
même être vigilant
alors une fois de plus je vous le dire
vous amusez pas piqué des téléphones
cette vidéo n'est pas là pour nous
apprendre comment voler les photos de
vos amis est vraiment pour vous
sensibiliser à ne pas laisser traîner
votre téléphone n'importe où car
quelqu'un de mal intentionné pourra très
très facilement venir voler vos photos
en autrement qu apple bien sûr corrige
le bug
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo dites
moi vous ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous connaissiez déjà cette
faille de sécurité est ce que vous
pensez qu'on nous a déjà appliqué du
contenu dans votre smartphone mettez moi
un petit peu ce que vous en pensez vous
invite à vous abonner à la chaîne
passera toujours toujours toujours plus
de contenu ou les amoureux de
l'high-tech on va parler d'eux
un peu un plein plein de nouvelles
choses abonnez vous mais témoignent tous
mettez-moi des commentaires et votre
être évitées d'ici là rendez vous
bientôt
[Musique]